Transcriber: Fatima Alwalidi
المدقّق: Walaa Mohammed
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته.
أنا إسلام مراسنة، كنت أدرس في جامعة
بوليتكنك فلسطين هندسة حاسوب،
وأنا اليوم مهندس حاسوب
في وزارة الاتصالات وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
وأكمل ماجستير ذكاء صناعي أيضًا في جامعة
البوليتكنيك .
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاة والسلام
على أشرف المرسلين سيدنا محمد وعلى آله
وصحبه أجمعين .
في البداية أحب أن تعرفوا أنني فخور جدًا
لأنني شخص من الأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة،
وسأبدأ كلماتي بأكثر
مقولة آمنت بها في حياتي والتي تقول:
"أن الإعاقة ليست إعاقة الجسد وإنما إعاقة
الفكر والروح،
إعاقة الإرادة، فعندما تتوفر الإرادة
الصلبة يستطيع الشخص أن يوظف قدراته
ويتجاوز العقبات ويحقق الأهداف
مهما كبلت جسمه القيود."
فهناك الكثير من الأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة الذين
لم تعيقهم إعاقتهم عن تحويل حياتهم من قصص
نجاح.
تحويل حياتهم من حياة عادية إلى قصص نجاح،
ناتجة عن إرادة صلبة وإصرار على تحقيق
الأحلام والوصول إلى الأهداف.
من بداية حياتي،
إلى عمر 18 عامًا
عشت حياة عادية.
كنت أمشي،
كنت أركض،
كنت شاب رياضي.
مارست لعبت الكونغ فو،
مارست لعبة الكاراتيه، قتال الشوارع.
كنت بلعب حديد، يعني نوعًا ما كان جسمي قوي.
ولكن بتاريخ
ثلاثين من شهر مايو
عام ألفين وخمسة عشر.
تاريخ لم أتمكن من نسيانه طوال حياتي.
تعرفوا لماذا؟ لأن في هذا التاريخ
انقلبت حياتي
مائة وثمانين درجة، ليس للأسوأ
من وجهة نظري انقلبت
للأحسن، انقلبت من حياة عادية لحياة مليئة
بالتحديات والمغامرات والنجاحات.
نرجع لتاريخ ثلاثين من شهر مايو
عام ألفين وخمسة عشر،
في هذا اليوم قدمت آخر امتحان تجريبي.
نعم، كنت توجيهي،
وكنت بالمرحلة النهائية منها،
كان باقي لامتحانات التوجيهي
تقريبًا شهر
فقط.
في هذا اليوم كنت أتمشى مع أصدقائي.
بعد صلاة المغرب بدأت أحس بوجع أسفل قدماي.
في البداية كان وجع بسيط فقلت:
هذا شد عضل سيذهب تلقائيا،
فلم أعطه اهتمام
وهكذا أكملت السير وعندما جاء وقت
صلاة العشاء ذهبنا نصلي للعشاء.
وأنا وأصدقائي في المسجد بدأت أصلي،
ولم أكن أعرف أن هذه أخر صلاة،
أصليها وأنا واقف على رجلي.
صليت بسرعة لأنه كان الوجع يزيد،
وعندما خرجت من المسجد،
أخبرت أصدقائي أن يوصلوني للمنزل
لأني شعرت أنني مريض.
وصلت إلى المنزل بصعوبة،
عندما وصلت إلى الدار،
استلقيت على الأريكة
وكان بهذا الوقت
الألم مر من قدمي ووصل إلى ظهري،
في هذا الوقت بدون ما أعرف
كان في حرب عنيفة،
حرب شرسة في جسمي بين التهاب فيروسي
وخلايا النخاع الشوكي.
لم أكن أعرف عن هذا الموضوع، لهذا اعتبرته
ألمًا عاديًا، ولكنه كان شديدًا،
لذلك أخذت قرص مسكن
وقرص منوم، وخف الوجع قليلًا ونمت.
استيقظت صباحًا، أردت أن
أنهض طبيعيًا كأي يوم لكن
لم أستطع أن أحرك قدمي،
لم يكن هناك أي حركة نهائيًا،
استغربت بالبداية استغربت حملت نفسي،
ساعدوني
أخوتي وأبوي وذهبنا للمستشفى بسرعة.
بالمستشفى بالبداية
استغربوا الموضوع استغربوا كثيرًا،
لم يعرفوا السبب الذي أوصلني لهذا،
لكن بعد كم يوم
وبعد ما عملوا لي أكثر من صورة اكتشفوا أن
هناك التهاب فيروسي داخل النخاع الشوكي،
ووصل لأخطر منطقة في الجسم
والتي هي النخاع الشوكي
قضى على أغلب الخلايا الموجودة
في أسفل العمود الفقري لدي.
قضى على أغلبها، وليس كلها، لهذا الإحساس
ظل موجودًا لكن الحركة اختفت نهائيًا .
عندما سمعت بهذا الكلام، انصدمت صدمة كبيرة
دخلت بحالة اكتئاب عميقة، قلت لماذا أنا؟
بذاك الوقت قالوا لي: أن حالتك هي نادرة
ونسبة حدوثها واحد على مليون.
قلت: لماذا أنا من بين مليون شخص؟
بالأمس كنت أتحرك،
واليوم بدون أي مقدمات صرت مقيد ومكبل
بهذا الكرسي.
بهذه الفترة حزنت ودخلت بحالة اكتئاب
يعني كان وضعي سيئًا للغاية،
ولكن جاء صوت من داخلي
بذاك الوقت، لأني توجيهي،
خرج من أعماقي صوت يقول أن
امتحانات اللجنة على الأبواب،
ولم يبق لها وقت
لا وقت للحزن والاكتئاب وهذا الهراء كله،
كان من المفترض أن أؤجل
تقديم امتحانات اللجنة إلى السنة التي تليها
لكن أيضًا لم أرد أن أضيع
مجهود الدراسة طول السنة،
لهذا صرت أمام أصعب تحدي
أتعرض له في حياتي
حزني على الشئ الذي صار معي من جهة،
وامتحانات اللجنة التي لم يتبق لها
إلا أيام قليلة من جهة ثانية.
قرأت الحديث الذي يقول:
"إن عظم الجزاء مع عظم
البلاء، وأن الله إذا أحب قومًا ابتلاهم،
فمن رضي فله الرضا، ومن سخط فعليه السخط."
وقرأت الآية التي تقول:
{عسى أن تكرهوا شيئًا
وهو خيرًا لكم،
وعسى أن تحبوا شيئًا وهو شرًا لكم،
والله يعلم وأنتم لا تعلمون.}
في حديث لسيدنا عمر بن الخطاب
يقول: "ما أبالي
لو أصبحت على ما أحب أو ما أكره لأنني
لا أدري الخير في ما أحب أو في ما أكره."
هنا فهمت أن الابتلاء رحمة من رب العالمين،
وأنه صحيح في ظاهره شر، لكن في باطنه يكون
فيه خير كبير.
وأنا أجزم وأكاد أجزم أنه لولا إعاقتي
ما وصلت اليوم إلى ما وصلت إليه،
ارتفعت معنوياتي بعد
هذا الحديث، ووجدت تحفيزًا وتشجيعًا من أهلي
ومن أصدقائي ومن طاقم المستشفى،
كنت في وقتها في جمعية بيت لحم العربية
للتأهيل لأخذ العلاج الطبيعي،
في المستشفى ووفروا لي
غرفة منفصلة لأدرس فيها.
وبعد هذا الشيء، بعد أن رأيت هذا التحفيز
والتشجيع والاهتمام،
قررت أن أترك كل شيء صار معي وراء ظهري
وأنعزل بشكل كامل عن العالم الخارجي،
وبدأت أدرس بصورة مكثفة.
لأستطيع أن أعوض كل الأيام التي راحت علي،
وبالفعل كنت أحصل على العلاج وأذهب إلى
الغرفة كي أدرس، وبفضل الله قدمت الامتحانات
بالجامعة وبنهاية الأمر حصلت على معدل سبعة
وثمانين فاصلة ثمانية في الفرع العلمي.
بهذا الوقت شعرت بلذة نجاح وانتصار
لا أتوقع أنه قد أحس بها
من حصل على تسعة وتسعين
وأخيرًا وبعد ما أنهيت امتحانات،
بعد ما أنهيت علاجي، عدت للمنزل
لكن ما عدت على قدمي
عدت على الكرسي المتحرك، بهذه الفترة
تحسنت، ورجعت الحركة لقدمي
لكن الحركة التي عادت ما كانت كافية
حتى توقفني على قدمي،
وعلى أمل أنه في يوم
من الأيام، الحركة تزداد لدي،
وأقدر أقف على قدمي.
بعد فترة من الجلوس في المنزل، جاء وقت
اختيار التخصص،
وأبدأ الحياة الجامعية، في البداية
سمعت حديث كثيرًا، “أنه كيف ستكمل الجامعة
وأنت بهذا الوضع، كيف ستدرس خمس سنين جامعية
تذهب وتعود إلى الجامعة،
ومواصلات وكيف وكيف وكيف؟”
لكن لم أهتم بكل هذا الحديث،
كان في مقولة تظل
في بالي، " أن من لا يسمع سيضطر العالم
إلى سماعه يومًا ما."
اخترت تخصص هندسة حاسوب، ولم يكن اختياري
لهذا التخصص بمحض إرادتي؛ اخترته لأن العمل
بمجال الحاسوب مناسب لوضعي الصحي.
واخترت أيضًا
جامعة بوليتكنك، لأنها الجامعة الوحيدة
في الخليل، التي لديها تخصصات الهندسة.
كان أكبر مخاوفي
أن أجد جامعة بوليتكنك غير ملائمة
للكراسي المتحركة
ولكن الحمد لله لما قدمت إلى الجامعة
وبدأت دراسة، كنت أتنقل بحرية
بين المباني والقاعات
واجهت بعض الصعوبات أثناء
دراستي في الجامعة، لكن بتعاون طاقم الجامعة
تمكنت من التغلب عليها كلها،
ولأن من لا يشكر الناس لا يشكره الله.
أتقدم بالشكر الجزيل لطاقم جامعة بوليتكنك
فلسطين الإداري والأكاديمي، ولا أنسى
الطاقم الجميل والرائع الذي هو طاقم الأمن؛
لأنه بصراحة؛ أكثر طاقم متعاون معي. كان معي
كرسي متحرك كهربائي، لم أكن أخذه إلى الدار
لأنه ثقيل، فكنت أضعه عند الأمن،
لما يخلص شحن
هم يشحنوه، وعندما يتعطل هم يصلحوه،
يضطروا مرات
يأخذوه بسياراتهم يصلحوه بالمحلات،
ربنا يجزيهم
كل خير.
بعد ما خلصت دراسة بكالوريوس هندسة أنظمة
الحاسوب في جامعة بوليتكنك، قررت أكمل
دراسة الماجستير في الذكاء الاصطناعي،
أيضا في جامعة بوليتكنك
لأنني صرت بصراحة أحس أنها بيتي الثاني،
أحس فيها بالأمان والطمأنينة
كملت دراسة الماجستير هناك، أقصد بدأت
دراسة الماجستير مع العمل كمساعد بحث تدريس
في الجامعة.
وبعد أن أتممت سنة من دراسة الماجستير
والعمل كمساعد بحث تدريس، تم بفضل الله
قبولي كمهندس حاسوب في وزارة الاتصالات
وتكنولوجيا المعلومات.
فرحت كثيرا أنني انضممت لوزارة الاتصالات
ولكن هذا ليس نهاية المشوار، وللحكاية بقية.
رسالتي أخيرا، رسالتي للأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة
لا يستسلموا إلا صغار العقول، فالإنسان
ما دام حيا يستطيع أن يصنع المعجزات.
لا تدع من إعاقتك معيقا، يعيقك
عن تحقيق أهدافك
فأنت قادر على النجاح والتفوق
في أي مجال تختاره، كون الإرادة والأمل هما
المفتاح الرئيسي لتجاوز التحديات وتحقيق
الأهداف.
اجعل من إعاقتك مصدرًا للقوة والإلهام
تتحدى به جميع التحديات والصعوبات.
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته.